hello
and welcome to morning show i mean
evening show
of chess on psychology here at the chess
club
we are having um a lot of fun in the
chess club there is a mini tournament
going out there it's nice to see people
so if you are in san luis run
make it here in person we're here for
next three hours
um jonathan you're so cute i
am a grandmaster just a woman title
it's okay you'll learn something all
right um
let's see i am actually having a fun day
a little kind of
butterfly pisha is also um having a fun
time there are a bunch of stray cats
coming around
but i might be flying him at some point
next month so we'll see how that goes
um speaking of flying a lot of the
people from the world cup are getting
flown out of russia because they keep
getting eliminated
so that's why we're here we did a kind
of a cool poll
and um saw that
you guys wanted to talk about the world
cup so
why not we're here to please um
from world cup so my top picks were like
fabi
or lavonne or dominguez you know local
people from here in san luis
which all got a little kicked out so um
yeah i have to pick a new favorite
so yeah maybe i should stop picking
favorites so my new favorite currently
is magnus because he's i mean
he's bound to win i mean i might as well
be right
about it and make some money off of a
bet
so let's go uh i'm actually not showing
any game from him i
wanted to show the game that he played
with atari but i also wanted to um
have a small have like a shorter game so
i could
fit in more than just one because
usually when we go
over one like 50 plus move game
we just cover it in the whole hour so we
want to do more than that
so the first um
yeah so this is kind of funny because
all three of these games black wins
um so i have three games ready for you
uh the first one is
uh one from the women's world cup which
is holding the same venue
i think the number participant is
actually half
so yeah i was feeling a little butterfly
um yeah so kind of spoiler warning sorry
i mean hopefully you're kind of caught
up with some of the stuff that's going
on in the world cup so
it's not going to be too spoilery
um so yeah the first one is
i um i've actually never played with
either of these players but they're very
strong
uh one grandmaster is an international
masters and i believe
yeah i think nino was the one that i was
playing the tournament in qatar masters
and she drew a magnus on the first round
i've
been wanting to show that one game maybe
um
maybe next week so let's go ahead and
get started
hold on actually first things first how
on god's green heart do i stop these
arrows
do not there we go i don't like these
arrows
there we go so
now do not speak spanish i'm looking in
the chat but
spanish does not help me
so the one of the big reasons i'm
showing this game
is because of the very cool tactic
that we will see towards the end of the
game
and so far uh there is not much to talk
about right now
actually i think today was the rest day
also here for juniors and seniors was
the rest day so
i mean i guess today is the rest day
everywhere
um so so far we have a very pleasant
normal spanish going on i kind of want
to know
uh what do you guys my live audience and
my
online people usually play against spruy
lopez do you actually get
on this could you actually get to this
position usually yeah
okay logical uh
is it hard to beat the lower rated
uh yeah no
good because i always thought i wanted
to confuse my opponents in the opening
so i always went through the weird
g6 d6 97 stuff
um let's see no
all right no preference i mean i don't
play against
i feel like this is amazing
oh okay yeah i tried our love with this
white i really like the queen e2 of
lines it feels quite tricky
anyhoo yeah
yeah we have one berlin in the chat too
all right so let's go let's keep going
what i usually do is
uh either earlier a6 or not i kind of
like to just get my
bishop fiance to it and then or like
start with a6
dc d6 knight e7 or something along the
lines of like
sometimes d6 early depending on how
confusing i want to be
um what else do we have yeah generally
if you try to do the fiance
i think those fiance got really famous
in 2014-15
a bunch of these giant players magnus
bobby all these players started playing
it so i
picked up back in five six years ago and
i still like it
yeah um nothing wrong with the normal
lines though
but what i wanted to emphasize is
specifically in these like palm
structures
so how do we feel
what do you think we should do
do we definitely don't want opponent to
get into
uh we don't want opponent to have these
two pawns isolated so
kind of limits our choices right
that sounds like the most logical one
that you should definitely consider
so that's definitely option number one
do we have an option number two or is
that it
that seems like to be the most logical
one right because
theoretically i mean yeah we could try
to maybe get the bishop out but
if we don't take it if we play anything
else let's say ah no we'll not that
if we get the bishop out then this is
not gonna be very pleasant
first of all there is a pawn flying off
of the board
but even if you weren't losing the pawn
this double pawns here
is just torturous we don't want that so
yeah we gotta take take
and now what do we do there i've seen a
lot of games like this growing up
from the first one that comes to mind is
nimzovich i don't know why
but there's always like ideally in the
middle game
um what do you think we should do where
does this bishop belong
should we push this pawn or not because
this is not a very
famous position right now you might know
the ideas of this pawn structure
but you don't necessarily have to know
the exact
move order of this so what do we think
yeah it should be seven so that
in case you ever want to play c5 it
protects the spawn and c6 in case
everyone plays c5 the bishop will be on
the line back and getting the king
excited
okay so you're um i agree right now we
have
literally three options either you're
gonna get this bishop out or you're
gonna push right now so what we're
trying to figure out is
should we push right now or no
i don't think there is a necessity to
push but
which one do you think um who has the
best potential to
make opponents um feel like
more which one is tricky so which one
can i
give the opponent the better chance of
making mistake
because a lot of chess is not
necessarily just about playing the best
moves but it's also about figuring out
how to make your opponent um
in a position that they have a hard time
finding the best moves
yeah i agree double pawns are not
necessarily that pretty
all right i feel like the chat is still
thinking we um yeah if we like bishop b7
it gives like
a lot of options maybe more so the one
problem so let's see what do you think
is the problem with bishop b7
what do you give to your opponents
uh yeah
too bubbly um you might not necessarily
jump in
there right now because that's i mean
you
you do want to play g6 on bishop g7
anyways
but um if you were to play like bishop
b7
then um i feel like white would just get
a little bit
more momentum and just like start
bringing pieces just a little bit faster
this is not losing by any means you're
more than i mean this is still
very playable and both players are still
developing but
it just makes it a tad bit harder for
black you have to kind of worry a little
bit more about
some things that you could have easily
prevented because if you plan to play c5
just do it right now
and then you you're kind of like um
it's decisive you could right now this
knight's got to decide
should it go back should it try to jump
around here
actually this is a mistake what do you
guys think this is a mistake
yeah exactly
simply take over here
and voila anyways um yeah so like
something like
knight c6 is also quite intriguing uh
because if the knight goes back well
i'll just develop now attacking over
here
and i can just develop and later on i'm
gonna reorganize get my bishop in the
big diagonal and my knights will be
useful here you can try to jump to e5
this is this is quite pleasant both
bishops and both long diagonals
we like it
alright so uh what about knight c6
do we have to worry about this
i mean our coin literally has one sword
to go so that's not the question
but now the knight also has only one
square to go
but so this knight from center it kind
of got into this
awkward corner
but at the same time we don't really
have bishop b7
anymore so is this a
a or an a for white
i
[Music]
knight on the side but black has a
problem with
his bishop i like it yeah so
just in a measuring opponent's misery
that's that this is this knight c6
makes opponent's life a little harder so
we like it
why would we go knight f3 and just wait
immediately for opponent to just get the
pieces out
so let's say yay it's also it's not even
stuck there right yeah yeah it's not
stuck yeah it can easily jump around
if needed and nobody can really attack
it right now anyways
so it's kind of bugging this the lack of
bishop
development so we could consider
something like g6
but your pizzas are very wobbly
so i wouldn't risk it there's just like
too much chances that
opponent could just cook something out
of your undefended pieces so just get
the bishop out
later on you can try to relocate the
bishop to f6
hello eduardo well why not i've been
here for
i've been here pretty much the whole
year and a half
what were you all right um
so yeah let's get these guys rolling
now we're in a position that we still
have to decide what do we want to do
with this bishop
if we can't develop it right now should
we consider exchanging cleans
if not then we should probably move one
of these rooks
because we we need to kind of be able to
um make a make it a little harder for
opponent as well we can't just
just respond to opponent's threats
it's a very fun table
i feel like it makes sense yeah i think
repeat makes sense too
so ideally we shouldn't necessarily want
to exchange queen oh well that's
stop badmouth we shouldn't that too
we shouldn't want to exchange queens
right away because
then we would give up this square and
this bishop is going to be problematic
but
i feel like if that wasn't the case if
he had a better grasp on the position
we could consider
exchanging queens because
it's the position is fine for the end
for
when the queens are i was gonna say end
game but just because the exchange
queens is not necessarily end game
so we don't necessarily know if we want
to exchange screens or not so let's go
with the move that we do know we want to
do so our b8
opponents could do b3 but
now we're gonna maneuver this knight two
over here
and then later on easily bishop f6 and
it'll be fun
we like that uh so rp8 why i just played
rugby one
develop uh i think taking should have
been played here because this bishop
is gonna become quite interesting later
on so we don't
it's better to not have to deal with
that so yeah
this would be a better choice yeah it's
a little uh
problematic maybe later on if we
were to actually gain more control of
the center but what to do now
so i think uh white should have taken it
but white decided to not
white decided to be a little tricky now
uh
dwight is like i want to take over here
first and then take your pawn
so now we gotta decide how much do we
care about this pawn
ah om that's very nice of you yeah i'm
i'm glad you like the karo khan
um are you trying to learn it from white
or black
because from white i really liked the
book i've pretty much been playing the
same variation with the negi
uh and as black one of my teammates
wrote the karaoke
book last year um
yeah i don't remember the name of the
book but for
white caro
black
and baldi there we go i think that's
what i had yeah
oh that knight history ah
well no that wasn't a nicki's book yeah
that knight history was not a nigga's
book
but the uh most of like the 97 knight f6
stuff where from there
yeah i think bishop eight makes sense
right we don't we don't necessarily
care about this pawn as much and if
you're gonna eat it anyways i'm gonna
try to keep my bishop why would i give
my bishop and let you eat the pond
so i'm gonna keep it now you take now
what do i do now we're in a
we're getting in the rhythm
the chat is quiet my live audience is
quiet
i lost 50 percent of them well ben will
be back but
maybe but your roof is doing okay right
now ah you're trying to go after the e4
pawn
that could that could that does make
sense but what about
uh your bishop on e7 because right now
these two pieces
like these are the pieces that could be
improved
yeah yeah i don't know i'm getting like
chat from like bishop b6 but why would i
put push your coin to go back in a good
spot same kind of with rook b4 because
when you play with b4 you're attacking
here but you're kind of pushing the
queen to go back
wait actually i think i made a mistake
but
that's the first thing but a3 also makes
sense because then you got to move the
stroke again
sorry it's okay
i'm not naming any names
um yeah also my
wisdom teeth are coming out it's so
weird
everything every morning i wake up i'm
like huh i
bite the inner cheek oh my god it's the
mess
i can't wait to be in my 30s and done
with teeth
growing
30 to 60 is a good age then after 60 the
teeth will start to go actually never
mind
i know oh
yeah teeth wise i wish i wish i was done
the teeth growing and
these problems
uh what are we going to do with the dark
square bishop that's the
that's the primary question yeah so
that's why uh there was a suggestion to
try to
shuffle this knight around so that we
could also get this bishop
so how do we like that i think knight g4
is actually very reasonable
you're just going to try to gain more
space with your knight
but um nino played the difference line
what do you guys think how do you feel
about
this
i like this night moving but d5 also
kind of looks fun right
i don't know if i would play d5 in the
real game because
i am a big fan of just moving this
knight around
but at the same time it does make sense
to want to
push d5 at some point
so something like right now d5 i kind of
like it
i kind of i'm having a little love-hate
relationship with it
because let's say take we take back
then what do we do
there's like yeah you open up the bishop
so that's good
but your pieces are not that ready and
uh white played the correct move white
played queen d3
and now what do we do we still have a
lot of development to do we don't
really have an attack just yet but this
bishop
is looking pretty sharp so for the price
of the pawn
i like this position i just kind of wish
my bishop was here
so yeah
so i like this right now what do we do
actually let's make my wish come true
let's get this bishop
i yeah uh let's make my wish come true
all right now what do we do
about my wisdom teeth i
i met up with the dentist last year and
i mean
october november and they were like your
wisdom teeth are coming at fine we don't
need to take him out
and he also told me that three out of
four will not come out
and two out of those three are coming at
as we speak
and it's so just weird it doesn't hurt
but
yeah next month i have a lot to do
i want to go to chicago for a few days
to get
the uk embassy louisa
then i'm gonna fly the kitty oh that'll
be fun
he's never been on a plane all right
let's come back to the chest a bit
um i'll keep you guys posted on
status of my flying cat well first he's
gonna go on a train actually
he's been on cars he's fine with that
all right
how do we feel about this position let's
come back to chest because if you let me
talk about pc
you will never end so
queen f5 ah
not opposed to it but i don't
necessarily know exactly where my queen
wants to go
ideally if i could get my queen to this
deck and all that'll be kind of cool
but
centralizing the queen's good but also
these rooks could benefit from some
movement
actually never mind i was thinking
rookie 8 but then this knight can go to
b3 and could get nasty
um maybe not
that but
i don't know why i don't like queen f5
you can't move the knight because of f2
but can you like maybe
okay you can't really kick the bishop
because then i'll just take over here
that's what i'm talking about wait no
why
why why dorsa stop talking
first calculate don't blunder
but not this just wait why is this wrong
seriously why is this wrong house
so i was initially correct to not like
this because you can take it
and knight can't take it because of
queen and if pawn takes it now you get
to take over here and take it over there
actually going to fight this interesting
the only problem with it is this knight
p3
because um white does want this knight
b3 anyway like right now
even right now might be could be
interesting but there is this knight
before
so that's why white played bishop d2 so
now they want to play this knight b3 so
in order to
how do we think we can't really stop
knight b3 but
what do you think we can do uh to be
fair i don't uh in my opinion
the best move here was not played in the
game
but the very practical move was played
you don't you're not going to be able to
see all the engine moves and they'll
find all the best moves
in your game but as long as you find the
practical ones
and you calculate better than your
opponent you should be good
sacrificing the exchange um
your pieces are not ready like if your
rook was like here yeah okay
i would do that i would sacrifice that
eating the pawn on b2 i mean
well you lose over here so this is this
is this pawn
over here is a good anchor
for your pieces
i keep kicking the table
now they still want this i had a very
fun
chat about seeing
flashes of light due to um
optical nerve being touched by teeth
roots and i have
i lost it for a second what
yeah i mean wait i don't know how that
would work
your obstacle hours or ah if it's
no i i know a
decent amount about humanity but
teeth is not my expertise
all i know is i don't want to have to go
to dentist
ever okay once a year
i tried to do one of these whitening
strips i
did it one time for an hour and my whole
like my teeth just felt like they were
falling out
it was like when you chew like gum and
then you do cold water for like
and i had to go to pharmacy and get like
a numbing gel
for my mouth yeah i learned my lesson i
like my teeth natural
you're very descriptive thank you
because i can also talk about the nail
on the chalkboard but
that never actually bothered me all
right um yeah so we're in a very uh
critical slash weird position opponent
wants a bunch of stuff
we potentially have a lot of things that
we want to do
but the biggest problem is we don't know
what to do about the night
and i don't think anybody can help us at
this point so
um this is the star
of your game we
would ideally like to keep this bishop
but if i have to choose between them i'm
going to keep
my light squared bishop so let's bring
more help for that
and this rook b6 it's a little bit weird
because
still nice b3 and i don't really know
how would block continue because you are
going to lose this
bishop and it's not it's not
i mean it's a little complicated and
this would give white a better chance
but so the best move here was actually
knight b4
i i agree it's a little weird and then
take you take it back with the rook
again c3 stuff done doesn't work because
you can take over here first
and then you can take over there and
there's a bunch of cool dropping
queens so that's that's
one thing to consider and if something
like that yeah but still like sea tree
is not a threat
and like you have these two cool bishops
this night and right now that night is
looking a little
ridiculous and this knight is also not
serving any purpose so like
you have a better position but it's
still complicated
knight before is the best move but drug
p6 is also quite practical
especially because opponent also made a
mistake
why is there these things here
bad leeches
how do i ah actually you know what
i'm not gonna mess with this i don't
know how to get rid of these let them be
yeah so c3 now what do we do this is
actually another critical position
because you have to try to figure out
because if you move this bishop well
then this knight's gonna jump around
you can you can't do this either
because well again this will fall there
is so what do you do after c3
that's why our v6 is so beautiful
because you have to have this
move ready against c3 and um
spice muffin yeah i did i saw that
morris ashley is gonna be covering it
which i think is very cool
um i i would want to watch that
so yeah nbc covering chess championships
yeah why not they should have done it
years ago
we also probably need like a sport one
of those cool um
chess models wait that doesn't make any
sense
what was i thinking about
ah yeah a few years ago sport
illustrator did like an interview like
they
followed me around in my campus for like
a whole day
i actually cleaned my dorm because they
were coming
and um like me
fabi and wesley three different days
they just kind of like followed us
around it's just so weird because i had
to like
get permission from my professors that
like
they could follow me around which again
i don't
i never understood what happened to that
interview that they did to take some
really cool pictures
i dressed up they never published it
neither one was like they didn't publish
mine fables or vesleys
that was like three years ago you said
sports illustrated yeah
it was during the us championships back
in 2018.
that's what's when it wasn't just online
maybe i never saw it because like they
had us all set up upstairs and then like
they sat us down they did this and then
they follow us around for a whole day
i want the pictures anyways
uh so what do we think
yeah unfortunately adidas got eliminated
yeah i'm sure you'll have another
chances to qualify for candidates
right yeah can we do
knight take c3 that that would be fun
wouldn't it
um the problem with knight takes either
i see what you want i see that you want
if the knight takes then you're gonna do
the nasty
queen eating but what if just the pawn
takes
you did my mistake yeah you forgot about
the knight
protecting the queen i did that mistake
about two minutes ago
so we said no to moving this bishop
right
we can't move the bishop we can't take
over here so
what's the other option
yeah so but how what should we attack
we're not touching these stuff so we
should be attacking
a piece of an equal value
i think a lot of us are making the same
mistake i'm getting a suggestion for a
night before what if just take
you don't have this the knight takes and
then the knights defending the queen
the queen is not free there will be a
knight defending it
we could attack these knights
i don't think attacking this might is us
enough because even if you do attack it
then this takes on the bishop is
defending the knight
so we should be attacking last night
yeah chad got it
yeah i think f5 is kind of fun
all right now what should we do here i
mean we're attacking this
if the knight moves away let's say the
knight moves away
now we can do all this nasty knight c3
and stuff because
there is no more knight defending f2 to
defend
the queen the whole circle
uh yeah so f5 is kind of fun
but and i think here
is what but white is already in a pickle
but white started to go
really bad really fast so take
now we take back something like queen h3
might have been a little
more interesting you pin me i pin you i
mean
still tries to gain some activity for
white but all right so take
take queen c4 keep in mind taking is not
that pretty because we have this bishop
here so all we gotta do is move this
knight
honestly before i want to go over here
yeah you know a bunch of different
options so
uh white want queen c4 to pin us how
much do we care about this pin because
if we care then we have to move if we
don't care
then we have some other targets to
attack
raymond that's funny i mean i don't
think anya was posed in a swimsuit for
sports illustrated they just walked i
mean phoned us around for normal stuff i
don't
walk around in bikinis so
i don't think fabi did that either i
mean
not that day maybe not that day
i know he's a physically active person
he's like very into sports tennis
swimming stuff but
i don't think that's a requirement for
sports illustrated
oh yeah queen five i like it let's go
for here
now queen of five let's say rook f1 and
right now yes position is already
collapsing
um here the best move is honestly to
just take over here
and your pawns are so so so pretty
you can't even really take back because
now i'll just have rook g6
and now this is another problem this is
like this is just collapsing
but uh black rushed into a little bit
and just played rooks g6 first white had
to take over here
white missed it that's what i'm saying
like a lot of chess is practical so
white missed this
and now this is a problem uh you would
have to play something like queen h3
and then bring your rook back because
you have to deal with these but
different that is like so much
you would kind of create more drama in
this whereas if you just took
it white can't just simply take back
because now rook g6
there is no pin and you kind of like
win a tempo you kind of win that um
you're not self pinning anymore yeah so
rick g6 white made a mistake and
now the correct move was played take
back and queen f3
queen f3 is such a logical move
you're not threatening checkmate right
away but you are kind of like
setting up you're going to the right
diagonal you're setting up to move these
pieces away
and i like it i really really really do
like it
queen c4 very easy king moves away
queen c5 chill stop e3
knight c4 all right now what do we do
this feels like our friday tactics
if i was light i would also be super
scared
probably about 10 months ago i would
start to but
i mean honestly knight f4 also should
give you some fun stuff
yep yeah
that would be very fun i actually really
like this
i wish actually this was played anyways
no white
don't don't play knight f4 yeah first
move the queen
um not queen eshwan though queenish one
there is this f3
guys this is made in three moves we can
do this
you're right about the ideas like
everybody sees the idea
you gotta this is something here but i
think we got a little over excited
yeah just go queen g2 voila you take it
check you remove it checkmate
wait does this check me checkmate yeah
what's more beautiful than this actually
i have an answer let's move it along to
fobby's game the one that got him
illuminated
kicked out yeah um
i'm gonna scroll through the the
beginning of this game quite fast
oh yeah because
i don't have much to say about the
opening and
i just really want
to get to that nasty night part
it was very fun because there's a lot of
cool meme online
about the opponent because
i think like in the opponent's culture i
have trouble
pronunciating so uh i'm gonna just go
with renat
i can buy it i can't say it
it gets funny for me and
so we'll just go with reenact that
should be it
yeah i say fabi we see rina there we go
let's have everybody
um in farsi with because which is like
cousins wait that's a very weird
translation okay um
let's just let's just get back to chess
of it because
yeah so i'm gonna scroll through the
beginning parts because this is a normal
car spot pawn structure with a bad
bishop
but it got very awkward for fabi
towards the middle game going to end
game
this is funny because this is a novelty
and
um i thought it was quite interesting g4
is usually
the main idea but this is
following the same path because of this
bishop and because of the pawn structure
white is hoping to do stuff in the queen
the king side black is hoping to do
stuff in the queen side
we got some normal stuff going on but i
am still scrolling because i really
really really want to get to that
nasty ending so
we're kind of approaching there now
about maybe 10 more moves i could have
actually started from position i don't
know why i did not do that
were you saying something about a meme
oh yeah i forgot about that
um the opponent has like i saw this
funny meme today like how
he used his knights and um
like in his culture it's very like
they're very good with horseback riding
so i should have had that meme ready
too late huh
dothraki i mean i think he could
qualify for because of this game yeah so
let's keep going for this game i'm just
trying to just
give you guys an idea of how we got to
that position i don't
necessarily want to talk about talk
about it
because uh this is not the point of this
game
the point of this game is to see how
actually fabika came below 2800 i'm a
i'm a big fan of him i don't know why
i'm showing this game yeah well too late
now
um so now is actually like
one of the first points that black
started to
play weird so we're gonna enjoy that
um so fabi's is still trying to form a
nice attack we got some good
bishops but
black still has extra material and this
pawn is also quite killing
so first things first right now
who do you want to be white or black
and don't look at this zero one over
here just look at the position
because this position doesn't determine
who's going to win
i really should have done this from a
position
all right i'm seeing two whites one
black two black
three blacks three whites
i guess that's
yeah so i mean white has an interesting
path
like pawn structure but black has this
extra exchange
so yeah
let's see what if right now if i told
you
there is a cool move called bishop of
seven would you still want to be black
which fall we found
so now you can't take it to the rook
because
that would be a good day actually
and this is falling there are a lot of
flying pieces that i've seen
watching the commentary so that's that's
the that's one of the positions that i
want to talk about because of this cool
bishop of saturn so
fabi actually got back in the game
because like five moves ago black was
black had clear advantage right now
white is still
holding white is trying this is like
i don't say equal but both have equal
chances
nobody's better um but black has two
rooks
and this past pawn so white's got to be
really careful
i like this king g2 move now black to
move what do we you know if i were found
it's probably he's playing as white well
we found the special song he did it
but fabi lost this position yeah
let's see blacktown what do we do
logically this rook is good over here
district is good over here so probably
the knights
right
yep okay let's get the knight rolling
and
okay probably played e4 a little little
dangerous but i mean
you have to and this now what do you do
with the king do you go back
or do you go up up is dangerous
but so is back so what do you think we
should do
hello chicago i'm actually hoping to be
in chicago
not this weekend next weekend if i can
get an appointment
we gotta go up right so let's see what's
wrong with king g1
or h1 yeah i said g1 because the h1 just
looks scary
what's wrong with king g1 what could
black do right now
no actually nobody's saying the correct
move
nope the knight is good where it is
because it's protecting this square so
the king can't come up
we got a good rook here because it's
cutting the king as well
what is the screaming the king in the
back rank
can't come up
what type of um checkmate ideas does
that give us
oops
yeah rk5 would be a good idea
and like you got to defend it like that
and now this coin is
stuck wait can we just do b3 oh wait no
there's queen g4 check
so let's just do h5 so we start playing
g4 check
then we want to slowly slowly push this
and
make it a fun game so yeah actually this
would be lost so fabi correctly found
king h3
black one knight g6 this is the meme
that i was referring to with the knights
so knight four is coming up what should
we do
i have to stop kicking the table
um
we know what black wants we're trying to
figure out what should what's the best
move for bobby has white
um layman actually fabi did play queen
c4
which was
did not work got really ugly
92 uh 92
is worth considering i just really don't
want him to quite i agree but the
problem with 92
just comes up and now i'm attacking i'm
gonna take over here i could bring
different rooks to g2
this is also just sad
so white has a single move that can hold
let's see if we can find it
no 92 doesn't work knight f5 i'll still
do knight f4 and i'll eat your queen
we're trying to save the queen queen
going to b3 or c4
does not work
queen a6 i'm not sure how that helps
there is still knight f4
i'm telling you there is a single move
that can hold
at this point i feel like people are
just shooting moves
all right all right i think we're
getting somewhere um
since everybody pretty much said every
other every possible
queen move so let's just
get going uh unless there's something
it's okay so queen e3 doesn't work
because
check up check buy
uh queen e2 doesn't work because kaboom
queen f1 doesn't work well there's a
rook here
uh queen c2 doesn't work because h5 and
i want to give you a very nasty
checkmate
same for queen c4 i still want to give
you nasty checkmates
queen b3 similar idea queen a6
i'm assuming similar idea i still want
to give you this nasty checkmate
so the problem is this nasty checkmate
the problem isn't just the check it's
the nasty checkmate
so in order to be able to stop it uh
you gotta fight back you gotta actually
attack something so let's go attack over
here
now if you give this check first king up
now i'm attacking over here and you
don't have
enough time to play these two moves
because your rook will fall
so that's why this could this is the
only move that could
save and then you just immediately start
attacking other pieces and then the
knight got a move
and then there's like other checks and
there's like a lot of stuff happening so
that's why we like it
that's why this should have been played
instead of
queen c4 queen c4 looks like such a
sophisticated move
but at this point we needed punch punch
punch stuff
yeah that would make a good thumbnail um
so queen c4 it is
that actually queen c4 is not and now h5
and there is a nasty checkmate coming up
yeah
i mean fabi missed it so it's okay if
you guys did so
i mean i'm pretty sure he'll he'll be
pretty sore about these nights for a
while
well there's sinful cup coming up so he
can't be that sore
um yeah he does have a pretty good
chance of getting back his
2800
anyways yeah uh h5 and we got this
pieces coming up the only way to defend
it is to
give up the night and
the night goes bye-bye and the rest is
just
painful there is still a lot of fight to
be done
because you know there's still three
pawns to a knight and two rocks but
you're king like
your king is just not doing not not
dirty
not holding it doesn't matter how much
you can push your king is the big
problem
and eventually you would lose these
pawns
one by one and a little inaccuracies i
don't think it matters that much
it's just painful see another another
nasty rook move with a knight coming up
yeah queenie one check
out which kind of hurts me to watch it
and kwabby just resigned
all right i'm i kind of wanted to do one
last one
but i'm not sure if we'll have time for
it this should be a really quick one
so we'll do this and then we'll do the
break and do the switch to twitch
so let's do this as the last game that i
wanted to show
uh wait nope nope nope
i wanted to look at it from white's
perspective because white made it around
wrong so yeah this is the position
we are looking at um black kind of
started to
black is going after this pawn right but
first things first let's just check our
end game understanding so black is
better right
i have an extra pawn but the problem is
that there's a bishop
and i'm eating this so is this the right
square is this the right pawn or is this
the right pawn which pawn should black
try to keep
let's say blah white will give up the
knight for a pawn
and which pawn do you think is best for
white to try to grab
why you should grab the paper yeah
exactly so it's important to be able to
grab
this pawn wait yes
not this pawn because your king will
have a safe spot right here
if there's this pawn left so taking over
here right now
doesn't help you however
we do have a but like something like
knight d3 also doesn't help you
because you're you can't reach this pawn
fast enough
and black will easily promote
and that's actually what happened in the
game and you can't stop it there's like
a knight c1 but okay i can stop it
so see that's like not that's not
unstoppable so knight d3 is the wrong
move what
is the right move
obviously symbol with the knight so
thank you about that
but um where to go
we said not to d3 we don't want to take
over here
we could that's so i think these are
your remaining squares
good luck my odds will ever be in your
favor
because literally this is like i either
you find the best chance of
having a draw or it's bye bye world cup
uh
so tell me more don't just don't just
give me a move so let's say
okay first of all knight h5 is bad
because i just take here
we establish that um
knight to g2 i'm not a big fan bishop of
two on your knight is kind of stuck
you'd have to go back so that's up too
um
so we have three three remain uh four
remaining options
which one gives you the best chance
exactly why does g6 look decent i'm
actually questioning that too
what's wrong with e6 i'll just take over
here
and what are you gonna do next like
knight over here okay i'll move it
your knight can't get to it in time so
e6 is also out
let's say you do play this knight g6 i
might play bishop g3 to limit your
knight yeah so i want you guys to
calculate that's
that's basically my thing four possible
choices
calculate i'll give you guys maybe just
another minute
and uh maybe i would appreciate it if
you don't just give me one
line one movie like tell me if knight i
don't know d5
black will take over here then we do
this like give me like about two moves
like
white does this black does this white
does despite does that knight g3
bishop g6 knight
e2 wait what
oh g6 knight g6
oh yeah
fair point and
yeah and you can't really stop that um
yeah let's see how how does the chat
feel
how do we like knight g6 then we could
potentially try to get to this pawn that
way because
the goal is to eat this pawn right so
how do we get there
e6 doesn't help us e6 i mean
it's a lot of hassle if you go knight e6
take
knight d4 i do want to do this but king
goes and then
it's not it's not in time we don't have
enough time
similar issue with knight e2 take
what are you going to do next knight d4
do you want to go there again i'll move
my king and move my pawn
we don't have enough that's why knight
g6 is the best one because i force you
to move your king
move your bishop and now if you do like
bishop d8
now i'll just go from this route and
this will fall
and if oh if you go bishop g3
again i'll go i'll get to c6
and i'll eat this and this is a draw
it's just very important to know that
this is a draw
yeah if the bishop is not controlling
the square that the pawn is becoming
queen
you're not comfortable to win it yeah
that's happened to me in one of my games
against when i was like 2100
against the international master and i
just wanted to
yeah you were there i was the victim of
you
i think i see one of my students here
nice yeah
good job nice so yeah now uh we're gonna
do a short
i think brick i don't know what to call
it switch to twitch so yeah we're gonna
switch to it and analyze your game so if
you have games ready
do send them over and we will analyze
them
make sure that they're in leeches
formats and make sure that
you'll be there in about i'm going to
say 10 minutes so
shouldn't take longer than that all
right everybody this is kind of fun
uh i can't believe next time or well
actually next
week we'll have a champion for
the juniors and seniors not the world
cup yet but
it's kind of fun to follow so make sure
to follow the world cup make sure to
follow
the seniors and juniors happening
and we'll see you in a little bit on
[Music]
twitch
you